Senator McCain will lie in state in the
Arizona State Capitol tomorrow at the
start of several days of final tributes
in Washington fellow senators open
yesterday's session with the prayer for
McCain his desk on the Senate floor was
draped in black with a base of white
flowers Nancy Cordes is at the State
Capitol in Phoenix Nancy good morning
good morning and trust John McCain to
find a way to have the last word on his
legacy and the current discourse it
turns out that he wrote a letter in the
closing days of his life that he hoped
would provide some comfort in what many
see as turbulent times these are John's
words my fellow Americans
McCain confidant Rick Davis struggled to
keep his composure at times as he shared
McCain's last letter to the nation I've
loved my life all of it
I've had experiences adventures
friendships enough for 10 satisfying
lives as Arizona says goodbye
McCain's colleagues are contemplating a
Senate without him he was bigger than
any one state he always belonged to
America and to the world and now he
belongs to the ages McCain had a habit
of finding friends and aides who stayed
loyal for good what was it about him
that drew people into this lifelong
affiliation he strove every day to tell
the truth and when he didn't he reminded
you that he hadn't told the truth in his
farewell letter McCain made a plea for
civility recalling his concession speech
to President Obama in 2008 we weaken our
greatness when we confuse our patriotism
with tribal rivalries we weaken it when
we hide behind walls rather than tear
them down we believe always in the
promise and greatness of America because
nothing is inevitable here Americans
never quit we never surrender
never hide from history we make history
thank you and God bless you and god
bless america
thank you
Davis joked yesterday that only John
McCain who would have turned 82 tomorrow
could rig a birthday celebration like
the one that's planned when he lies in
state here at the Arizona Capitol
building tomorrow he will be only the
fourth person John to do so since 1972
Nancy thank you